bonsoir abonnés le premier ministre a
donc annoncé de nouvelles mesures à
l'assemblée pour tenter d'empêcher la
diffusion du variant brésilien en france
où il aura fallu attendre plusieurs
jours de tergiversations pour que enfin
le gouvernement annonce des restrictions
fortes concernant donc les vols en
provenance du brésil je propose
d'écouter jean castex le premier
ministre c'était cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale
nous constatons que la situation
s'aggrave et nous avons donc décidé de
suspendre jusqu'à nouvel ordre tous les
vols entre le brésil et la france
alors après ces annonces il reste quand
même encore quelques inconnues quid des
autres pays d'amérique latine où le
variant circulent également et puis quid
de la guyane qui on le rappelle possède
une très grande frontière terrestre avec
le brésil il faut noter que avant ces
annonces jusqu alors les règles étaient
assez floue en la matière avec des
avions qui continuait d'atterrir
quotidiennement sur le territoire
français en provenance du brésil avec
pour seule contrainte pour les voyageurs
le fait de présenter un test pcr
négative datant de moins de 72 heures et
à déclarer sur l'honneur lors de leur
arrivée en france qu'ils allaient
respecter une période d'isolement de dix
jours et puis du côté du gouvernement il
ya encore très peu de temps jusqu'à ce
week-end on se voulait plutôt rassurant
en appelant ans je cite à l'engagement
et à la responsabilité de chacun écouté
par exemple le ministre clément bonne il
ya très peu d'arrivées d'habitude vous
avez près de 50000 personnes qui
arrivent du brésil on est à mille par
semaine aujourd'hui on a été très
sérieux sur la fermeture des frontières
un nouveau revirement pour le
gouvernement thomas qui a donc cédé à la
pression d'élus et de scientifiques qui
alerté depuis déjà plusieurs jours sur
la menace de ce mariage
l'air du brésil oui ça fait un moment
que des voix s'élèvent pour attirer
l'attention de l'exécutif sur le risque
que peut représenter ce nouveau variant
ce variant que l'on appelle p1 qui
seraient en grande partie responsables
de la flambée épidémique au brésil et il
ya une donnée qui inquiète
particulièrement
la majorité des brésiliens souffrent du
coït 19 en soins intensifs ont désormais
moins de 40 ans invariants qui serait
également plus contagieux et plus
résistants aux vaccins c'est donc une
menace prise très au sérieux par les
scientifiques qui craignent que ce
variant ne devienne majoritaire en
france provoquant alors une nouvelle
augmentation des contaminations alors
pour l'heure selon des estimations ce
variant représenterait moins de 5% des
contaminations en france et dans le même
temps thomas on a appris aujourd'hui que
le déploiement du vexin johnson and
johnson était retardé
oui cela fait suite à la décision
américaine de suspendre l'utilisation de
ce vaccin qui serait à l'origine de la
formation de caillots sanguins au moins
six cas ont été rapportés ces derniers
jours aux états unis avec une personne
notamment qui est décédé lors les
autorités sanitaires ont décidé de faire
une pause dans les infections du vaccin
johnson & johnson
conséquence le déploiement en europe est
lui aussi repoussé ce risque ce qui
risque d'avoir un impact très concret
pour le calendrier fixé par le
gouvernement il faut rappeler que la
france a reçu hier deux cent mille doses
de ce vaccin johnson & johnson
ouais merci thomas bonne et on direct de
l'assemblée nationale